so one of the assumptions is that
humanitarian aid workers often work in
the field which is um
we need to clarify a bit first what is
actually the field the field can be many
things
if you look from from headquarters in in
brussels or geneva the field can already
be
kabul or bangy or another capital city
well if you sit in kabul in an office
then provincial or even a smaller town
can be the field
and for many of us work will happen in
offices work will be behind a computer
not
every one of us will be out in let's say
refugee camps or
on on difficult border crossing stations
where where people
are are crossing under difficult
circumstances
so many of us will will not be in what
immediately would be perceived as
the field and yet we are all doing
humanitarian work there
i think one of the important things to
keep in mind is also if you really want
to work in
let's call it the field um is how
well are you able to work there how well
do you fit in do you
do you do you know the cultural codes do
you know the language are you actually
able to be of an added value where you
are
and i think this is one of the very
important reflections people
always need to have when they want to go
into humanitarian work
is where do i bring an added value
you